c'est la seule chose qu'elle ait trouvé
pour ne pas mourir de faim une
cueillette qui lui demande un effort
considérable
y'a quoi tu n'as plus que ça pour se
nourrir depuis maintenant deux semaines
[Musique]
l'angola mam sont les feuilles que je
ramasse c'est pour les manger elles sont
comestibles et j'ai rien d'autre faut
que je me débrouille toute seule mon
mari est mort
[Musique]
une heure pour ces quelques feuilles de
la l'ofppt un arbre qui résistent à la
sécheresse
et pour compléter des baies sauvages
cueillies sur ces arbustes de ryad
quel et les siens consomme quand ils
n'ont plus rien
on mange cb avec mon fils c'est très
amer mais on les mange quand même je
l'écueil je les lave je les cuis et
après on les mange ya quoi tu vis dans
cette ut qu'elle a construite elle même
elle y habite seul avec son fils de
quatre ans
[Musique]
les feuilles et les b ne nous suffisent
pas quand il pleut avec la boue c'est
impossible d'aller jusqu'aux à elle a
fui le conflit qui ravage le soudan du
sud est trouvé refuge ici à paddec une
localité du nord du pays
elle est arrivée il ya deux semaines
après avoir marché cinq jours le ventre
vide pour échapper aux combats où son
mari a trouvé la mort
je n'avais jamais vu une telle violence
j'ai eu tellement peur les enfants
étaient en train de jouer quand on a
entendu des tirs
tout le monde est parti en courant dans
toutes les directions j'ai juste eu le
temps de prendre le plus petit et j'ai
dû laisser mes deux autres garçons je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils sont devenus
cette guerre a séparé plusieurs familles
c'est une sale guerre comme il ya quoi
tu 20 millions de personnes sont
menacées par la famine au yémen en
somalie au nigeria et au soudan du sud
l'onu annonce la pire crise humanitaire
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale ceux
qui ont faim ne subissent pas seulement
les aléas climatiques mais la guerre en
fuyant les combats dans leur pays ils
ont laissé derrière eux leurs champs
leurs cultures leurs bétails
ils ont perdu tous leurs moyens de
subsistance au soudan du sud depuis 2013
le pouvoir en place et l'opposition
s'affrontent dans une guerre civile
chaque camp représente deux ethnies
principales les dinka et les nuers 3
millions de sud-soudanais ont été
déplacées selon les nations unies
c'est un quart de la population dans ce
pays les humanitaires font face à une
situation d'urgence absolue
[Musique]
tombé du ciel huit tonnes de nourriture
s'éparpillent sur le solde de paddec
dans cette ville au nord du pays
seul les avions de la croix rouge
apporte ton corps à manger je n'avais
jamais vu de nourriture tombé du ciel
et quand l'avion fait tomber ses sacs
t'as pas intérêt à rester trop près si
tu ne veux pas en recevoir un sur la
tête c'est du sordo ça tombe bien on ne
mange presque que ça la gagne
aucune route n'existe pour arriver ici
[Musique]
face à l'urgence alimentaire la croix
rouge a exceptionnellement louer cet
avion tous les jours pendant un mois
christophe est le représentant du cicr
sur place et
et lionel et où c'est lui qui organise
la distribution des vivres
il travaille au soudan du sud depuis
cinq mois déjà de la casse alors des
rouges 700 euros les verts c'est les
échos et puis après et des bleus qui
sont le sucre bien à moins et puis les
blancs c'est le siège le cicr n'avait
passé de largage alimentaire dans un
autre pays que la somalie depuis 1986
l'avion passe ici deux fois par jour les
familles reçoivent de quoi tenir un mois
81 kg de sorgho une céréale locale
un kilo de sucre 1 kg de sel et 20 kg de
haricots nous faut quand même une heure
de récoles et d'empilage ensuite une
bonne demi heure pour distribuer en fait
pour que les gens y viennent et puis qui
se partagent la pile et qu'ils
l'enlèvent de la piste à tour de rôle
les familles viennent se partager les
vivres c'est bon vous pouvez y aller
allez-y
pour obtenir de la nourriture il faut ce
précieux sésame
un ticket bleu distribué par les
humanitaires pour l'obtenir il suffit de
s'inscrire sur la liste des demandeurs
auprès de la croix-rouge et chacun peut
recevoir son ticket sans condition ap
avec les locaux et les déplacés de
guerre cohabitent mais tous ont besoin
des deux alors là c'est la distrib elle
même c'est des groupes de 20 familles
qui arrivent elles vont être placés cinq
par cinq
chaque ligne représente cinq familles et
là ils vont leur expliquer comment se
départager le tas et puis après les gens
ils doivent partir avec les sacs ici
réfugiés ses habitants sont tous de la
même ethnie les nuers un lien
communautaire fort tout le monde accepte
de partager la distribution se déroule
sans incident sous une chaleur écrasante
il faut maintenant transporter ces sacs
une tâche difficile pourtant laissé aux
femmes
beaucoup d'hommes sont partis à la
guerre elle marche parfois pendant deux
heures avec 50 kg sur la tête
même enceinte en guise de salut
l'avion passe une dernière fois en rase
mottes c'est la première distribution à
laquelle participent regina je suis
contente vraiment contente j'ai soif
mais ça va bon faut que j'y aille chez
du chemin l'histoire de regina et celle
de la violence de la guerre elle a fui
sa région natale où elle a tout perdu
pour venir s'installer ici comme tant
d'autres selon la croix rouge
la population a doublé paddec comptait
dix mille habitants
il y en a aujourd'hui vingt mille tous
les mois de nouveaux rescapés arrive
aucune route adapté à des véhicules ne
mène ici coupé du monde
pas des coffres donc un refuge loin des
conflits
la ville s'étend sur une quinzaine de
kilomètres les utiles sont souvent
éloignées les unes des autres
le centre du village n'existe pas
vraiment si ce n'est ce puits où chacun
vient s'approvisionner en eau
regina est arrivé ici après une attaque
contre son village dans le sud du pays
[Musique]
on était à la maison les soldats sont
arrivés en 4 4 ils ont tiré sur tout le
monde nous sommes tous partis en courant
mais il continue à nous mitrailler ils
ont tué des femmes et des enfants
d'autres comme moi ont pu fuir avec les
leurs son mari un soldat de l'opposition
a été tué
elle a rejoint de la famille ici à
paddec habitants et réfugiés se
partagent les maisons et les vivres ça
c'est le sorgho que j'ai ramassé sur la
piste
je vais d'abord nourrir mes enfants
quand on n'a plus rien à manger je
cueille des feuilles dans les arbres
le problème avec ces feuilles c'est que
l'on risque d'avoir des diarrhées et des
vomissements
voilà bah mon petit garçon ben il est
malade
cuisiner en bouillie le plat de sorgho
permettra de se coucher un peu rassasié
[Musique]
au petit matin christophe le chef de
mission de la croix rouge par faire le
tour des huttes pour voir si chaque
famille a bien reçu sa ration de
nourriture
bonjour toutes les deux elles ont juste
1,5 et demi de sel pour elle de ses
seins bientôt les avions ne pourront
plus largué leur précieuse marchandise
car la saison des pluies approche les
habitants de baddeck devront alors se
débrouiller seul christophe profite de
son tour du village
bonjour pour savoir comment ils vont
faire ce qu'ils font est qu'à sa
coquille et ça il le jette où ils le
mangent ils la cuisse d'abord la font
sécher au soleil et après ils la manche
aller cette graine on la trouve toute
l'année oui l'on mange toute l'année
partie de leurs besoins nutritionnels
vient de la cueillette avec la chasse et
à la pêche dans certains endroits mais
pas ici
ici on cultive le sorgho une céréale peu
gourmandes en eau mais pas facile de
faire pousser quoi que ce soit le
matériel est sommaire
bon elle a des graines hockey alors
qu'est ce qu'elle fait si tu plante une
graine tu la mets où la deuxième
laplante ici ainsi loin les grèves n'ont
pas besoin d'être aligné il faut juste
qu'il y assez d espace entre chacune
comme ça la terre nourrit bien la plante
kent une fille mais la technique ne
suffit pas toujours
la saison sèche qui dure neuf mois durci
les sols lorsque la pluie arrive en
juillet août et septembre
l'eau ne s'infiltre pas et inondent les
terres l'année dernière on avait bien
semer dans nos champions et on a tout
perdu avec les inondations maintenant on
essaye de replanter mais on a peur que
la pluie reviennent aujourd'hui un
nouvel avion de la croix rouge doit
survoler paddec yakult la cueilleuse de
feuilles n'avait rien eu la dernière
fois faute de tickets il avait été
distribué juste avant qu'elle arrive au
village
cette fois elle supplie l'organisateur
d'en avoir un mais oui il ne faut pas
t'inquiéter tu l'auras le ticket
aujourd'hui on m'a dit que j'aurai un
ticket en me l'a bien dit pour ja quote
c'est l'assurance d'un repas quotidien
riche en protéines elle manque
cruellement dans les feuilles et les
graines vous ne pourrez recevoir de la
nourriture que si vous présentez le
ticket de toute façon on vérifiera sur
la piste je vais faire l'appel et si
quelqu'un essaie de tricher je le verrai
alors n'essayez même pas
pour ya quoi tu sais ça que venu du ciel
c'est inespéré
elle va pouvoir nourrir son fils
je suis tellement contente d'avoir reçu
mon ticket je suis heureuse parce que
mon fils va enfin pouvoir manger et pour
une fois il ne se couchera pas le ventre
vide
c'est incroyable de recevoir de quoi
manger sans que ce soit le fruit de mon
travail je suis contente
allez on y va pour l'occasion y'a quoi
tu as même mis son unique collier
quelques perles jaune autour de son cou
un peu perdu elle avance inquiète de
rater son tour et c'est mon sac mais
prend n'importe lequel on partagera
après et c'est le moment tant attendu
rentrés à la maison les mains pleines
[Musique]
sur le chemin yako est henri tout seul
de bonheur en la voyant son fils arrive
tout excité sa maman lui donne tout de
suite une poignée de sucre
[Musique]
nous je lui donner du sucre parce que ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a rien eu à
manger
c'est la première fois de sa vie qu'il
en coûte il a quatre ans mais il n'a
jamais rien mangé de sucre et je suis
tellement heureuse de lui donner à
manger qui n'arrive même plus à tenir
debout
je suis pressé de cuisine et maintenant
si on n'avait rien mangé pendant encore
trois jours je pense qu'on serait mort
de faim au moment où ils ont eu à cowes
si j'avais des semences je pourrais
cultivé mais pour l'instant je n'ai rien
vous voyez cette heure elles sont très
fertiles
si je pouvais cultivé et ça irait déjà
beaucoup mieux si l'ennemi vient nous
attaquer encore une fois je serai obligé
de partir une fois que les combats
commencent tu es obligé de fuir mais je
n'y pense pas là je suis avec les gens
de ma communauté
mais si ça arrive je ferai encore mange
lentement la casserole de haricots n'est
pas resté longtemps sur le feu on a
tellement faim qu'on n'a pas la patience
d'attendre la fin de la cuisson
et puis si on mange petit à petit on
pourra peut-être garder notre stock plus
longtemps pour l'instant yakou et
échappe à la guerre mais et les
condamnés à avoir faim
à 350 kilomètres de padt ecc dont le sud
du pays la situation n'est pas meilleure
en ville aussi la fin creuse le ventre
des soudanais même à djouba la capitale
avec le conflit
l'industrie pétrolière la seule du pays
s'est effondré
la crise économique s'est installée et
les prix des denrées ont explosé 800 %
d'inflation en 2016 selon le programme
alimentaire mondial en france ce taux
est de 0,2 pour cent dans cet hôpital du
centre ville des parents en quête des
dames n leurs enfants surtout des mamans
seules ici garçons et filles pestons
moyenne la moitié du poids normal d'un
enfant du même âge
[Musique]
samson yamaha et nutritionniste à chaque
arrivée il fait un premier bilan du
jeune patient à l'attaqué je vérifie
avec ce maître quand on veut savoir si
l'enfant est malnutri le rouge indique
que l'enfant est sévèrement malnutris le
jaune indique un stade modéré et le vert
c'est normal doit être ni trop serré
nitro l'âge est là tu prends la mesure
c'est 9,45 il est sérieusement malnutris
mari qui êtes arrivé hier
yauque son fils à de fortes diarrhées
car elle n'a pas pu lui donner une
nourriture adaptée à un an et quatre
mois il pèse 6 kg il devrait en faire
dix leur histoire aussi est celle de
victimes du conflit
je suis là à cause du conflit
j'ai fui les combats mon mari était
soldat et quand il est mort j'ai dû
quitter y est ma ville pour venir à
dubaï et je pouvais aller chercher à
manger c'était moins cher on pouvait
aller chercher au chant les légumes ou
les cultiver aduba tout est plus cher et
tu ne trouves rien en dehors des marchés
le niveau de vie des sud soudanais est
parmi les plus bas d'afrique 1 euro par
jour
ces femmes gagne ton corps - pas assez
pour se nourrir
y at il des enfants qui meurent de
malnutrition
quand les enfants meurent de
c'est souvent parce que les parents les
ont gardées trop longtemps à la maison
avant de venir à l'hôpital
il arrive parfois inconscients et comme
il faut un peu de temps pour mettre un
traitement en place et surtout pour que
ce traitement agissent il est parfois
trop tard et il meurt le petit makoura
un an et demi il pèse 5 kg il devrait en
faire 11
son état est critique c'est la troisième
fois que sa maman a well vient avec lui
comme beaucoup d'enfants
il cumule malnutrition est une maladie
courante ici le sida à la maison il n'y
a pas à manger quand j'ai un peu
d'argent j'achète de quoi faire une
soupe et je lui donne parfois on arrive
à avoir un bout de chèvre ou du poisson
séché
mon mari m'a abandonnée il a une autre
femme
je n'ai pas de travail je fais que des
petits travaux ce que je peux mais je
peux pas m'occuper de l'enfant et
travailler donc j'ai rien 40% de la
population est en insécurité alimentaire
selon les nations unies
autrement dit avec un accès restreint la
nourriture mais la déclaration de famine
signifie que désormais au delà d'être
sous nutris on peut mourir de faim
la maman du petit ma cour l'a laissé
faire une sieste mais les médecins ont
soudain un doute
m
makuch un an et demi est mort dans son
sommeil à wels sa maman vient d'être
prévenu un enfant meurt chaque mois de
malnutrition dans cet hôpital mais aucun
chiffre n'existe au niveau national
[Musique]
dépassé par la catastrophe
le gouvernement a donc déclaré l'état de
famine dans une partie du pays
en février dernier il espère une
mobilisation et une aide de la
communauté internationale l'onu évalue à
un milliard et demi d'euros les besoins
de financement pour endiguer la crise 27
% seulement ont été réunies une aide sur
laquelle se repose clairement le
gouvernement et son ministre des
affaires humanitaires
hussein maghnia tu les gens souffrent la
situation se détériore et c'est de pire
en pire foudre car il y à une insécurité
alimentaire et les gens ne reçoivent pas
à manger
nous apprécions toujours l'aide des
nations unies et l'aide internationale
mais ça ne suffit pas et nous avons
besoin de plus pour que cette situation
soit renversé freewest le gouvernement
si soucieux du sort de sa population est
pourtant soupçonné de laisser à
l'abandon les régions acquise à
l'opposition
selon l'onu les zones touchées par la
famine sont effectivement celles des
adversaires du pouvoir
impossible de poser une question sur ce
sujet sensible
plusieurs journalistes ont déjà été
reconduits à la frontière très peu de
médias dans ce pays en guerre
on y meurt de faim en silence
depuis 2013 le conflit oppose le
président salva kir de l'ethnie dinka
à son vice président riec machart de
l'ethnie nuers pour les élections
présidentielles le vice président a
voulu se présenter face au chef de
l'état une affaire d'ambition qui a
tourné au conflit ethnique
des émeutes éclatent et marque le début
de la guerre civile depuis à la sortie
de la ville
un camp où vivent 45 mille réfugiés
majoritairement nuers a été installé
placé sous protection des nations unies
pour leur propre sécurité
ils dépendent totalement de l'aide
alimentaire ils ont tous fui les combats
marta est arrivé au début de la guerre
civile
aujourd'hui la croix rouge lui organise
une liaison satellite avec son mari elle
ne lui a pas parlé depuis trois mois
comment va la blessure de la belle mère
comment va sa jambe blessée
et voilà
hélas
ici on souffre beaucoup la vie est
difficile demande si ninja elle peut
venir nous aider
c'est fini il faut que je raccroche
non mais on me dit content est terminée
je demandais à mon mari comment vont les
choses parce que là où il est dans le
nord il y à des combats ils ont dû se
cacher dans les marécages et ils n'ont
rien à manger
tous les nuages restent ici au moins je
suis avec les miens et de toute façon si
on sortait du camp on se ferait tuer on
ne dépend que de l'assistance
alimentaire
on n'a pas d'autre moyen d'avoir de la
nourriture en 2016 le camp a été
attaquée 12 réfugiés et deux casques
bleus ont perdu la vie depuis le début
du conflit
82 humanitaires ont été tués les
belligérants essaye de bloquer l'arrivée
de l'aide alimentaire
les ong doivent se protéger et
n'arrivent pas à accéder à certaines
zones
ian read est le chef du bureau de
coordination des affaires humanitaires
des nations unies
c'est le pays le plus dangereux au monde
sur un trajet de djouba à bento par
exemple dans le nord du pays
il y a environ 100 checkpoint sur la
route
certains sont légaux mais beaucoup
d'autres sont illégaux et pour cela on
va nous demander de payer pour avoir le
droit de passer ici toute la vie
s'organise au rythme de cette guerre qui
tue et affament même dans la capitale
des combats peuvent éclater à tout
moment
à l'aéroport un convoi exceptionnel de
la croix rouge se prépare
séparés par la guerre ces enfants par te
rejoindre leur mère qu'ils n'ont pas vus
depuis quatre ans il s'envole pour my
voûte dans le nord du pays près de la
frontière éthiopienne où leur maman
s'est réfugié lorsque les combats ont
commencé
elle était partie à plusieurs kilomètres
du village pour chercher à manger
elle n'a pas pu rentrer à temps ces
enfants ont fui avec le reste de la
famille vers la capitale pour se placer
sous la protection des casques bleus
[Musique]
que dieu est puissant il a été capable
de me rendre mes enfants je lui en suis
reconnaissante merci merci c'est un
miracle dieu m'aide à monter les marches
qu'il m'aide à garder mes enfants pour
toujours protège moi avec t'accroches
heureux si heureuse ils ont changé mais
je les reconnais ce sont mes enfants
quand même j'ai été séparé de mes
enfants pendant quatre ans je n'ai
jamais pu pendant toutes ces années
partir les rejoindre à djouba où la
violence est trop importante envers les
gens de mon ethnie avant j'avais des
champs mais comme maintenant je n'ai
plus rien je vais devoir les emmener
dans un camp des nations unies en
éthiopie
un jour peut-être cette maman et ses
enfants reviendront au soudan du sud
tous ensemble au même moment deux autres
avions atterrissent avec quatorze
blessés à leur bord
il arrive de la ligne de front deux
watts à 200 km de là il y a quatre
blessés à 6,3 sur des brancards et deux
en état critique
ils vont être emmené à l'hôpital de la
ville
créée en 2014 un an après le début du
conflit
je quitte la piste avec un homme blessé
sur un brancard
ça a l'air d'aller son état est stable
ou pas oui il est stable l'hôpital de
mail goutard armes ont reçu autant de
blessés aujourd'hui ils sont proches de
la centaine le point de rupture pour les
équipes
le centre hospitalier de mails goûter le
dernier à pratiquer la chirurgie de
guerre en zone d'opposition vous pouvez
lui faire le dépistage de la malaria
civils ou combattants cet hôpital ne
fait pas la différence
ici tout le monde a le droit d'être
sauvé d'autres blessés arriveront encore
le conflit n'est pas près de s'arrêter
oui dans lequel on n'a pas peur je pense
même rejoindre l'armée rebelle et je
pourrai libérer ma ville
cette ville elle est à nous ils essaient
de la reprendre mais on ne va pas les
laisser faire on se basera vraiment s'il
le faut les blessures sont celles de
kalachnikov en urgence l'équipe médicale
doit tenter d'opérer un jeune soldat de
l'opposition
une balle lui a perforé le ventre et une
partie de ses intestins sont sortis ils
risquent de mourir comme il était
inconscient quand il est arrivé
mais là on voit qu'il bouge un petit peu
il réagit bien à la perfusion
l'opération va durer trois heures
[Musique]
mais peu de temps après l'intervention
le jeune soldat meurt il est enterré
tout à côté au bord de la route
sans même un nom pour l'identifier mais
avec une prière 50000 sud-soudanais
auraient été tuées depuis 2013 selon les
nations unies
mais en réalité ici personne ne compte
vraiment les morts ni ceux de la guerre
ni ceux de la fin
[Musique]